[Music]
d is with us days in detroit michigan hi
dee how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
okay um i am retired i'm a widow and i'm
debt free
um and my problem is that my house needs
some updates and repairs
i've been getting estimates the
estimates uh seem like everything is uh
three four five times what i expected to
pay
um and what i'm looking at is i'm
looking at getting a line of credit to
do the repairs and and the labor labor
saving updates because i'm 63.
versus um using my savings but i i
wasn't going to go beyond what i have to
you know that like what if i was going
to pay cash for
so i what i wanted i just wanted to get
some advice from you
um do you think that's a good idea
uh do you advise something else or what
but you know the house needs to be
updated how much in repairs is the total
probably about 50 60 000
and how much money do you have in your
total world
well i got more than 60 how much money
do you have in your total world
in my total world i
have 500 000.
okay
dee you have done a really good job
fix your house with your money
use money and fix your house don't use
debt and fix your house
not a line of credit nope
why would i put you back in debt you're
my friend
well because i'd rather have my money
working for me it's not working for you
you're paying the bank you're paying the
bank well okay we'll see there's another
caveat
problem is um
i always have to pay taxes every year
and if i took a line of credit
i was thinking that that would help
reduce
if you want to if you want to do that
all you have to do is give more to your
church
pardon me you give more to your church
you'll have the exact same mathematical
effect you don't go in debt
if you want to if you want to lower your
tax bill increase your charitable giving
well i've been doing that same thing
listen if you give the bank ten thousand
dollars which you're not going to if you
give the bank a thousand dollars in
interest
okay
you know what it saves you in taxes
no 200
really yep
tax deduction is not a tax credit it's a
deduction and so it reduces your income
that is taxable by one thousand dollars
as applied to your tax rate and in your
situation the way you're the way you're
structured in the way your life's set up
you're probably have an effective tax
rate of around twenty percent maybe it's
thirty percent but it saves you two to
three hundred dollars the other seven
hundred dollars is just burned you
didn't make a thousand by giving them a
thousand so you gave them a thousand to
say to not give the government 200.
i don't want you doing that if you want
to do that give your church an extra
thousand that way you don't have to give
the government 200.
and you don't even have to be in debt to
do that one
okay um is there a way that i if
somebody told me that if i if i
incorporate
hey dee you're listening to a lot of
stupid people
yeah
who are you i don't know who's in your
ear but they're dumber than a rock
i don't know who this is you don't need
to incorporate you're a 64 year old
widow trying to fix her house
you got 500 thousand five hundred
thousand dollars fix your freaking house
just fix it and then i don't have any
nightmares and if you wanna turn a
thousand dollars into a two hundred
dollar tax deduction just increase your
charitable giving by that you don't have
to be in debt for that it's the exact
same
ratio
here's a promise i'll make you d if you
mail
um a thousand dollars to ramsey
solutions here in nashville i will mail
you two hundred dollars
that's a personal promise
if you want to make that trade john
deloney has a system to do it i will in
fact this isn't just for you dee this is
for anyone in america
a thousand dollars to the ramsey
solutions building you're going to get
me arrested personally mail you 200 cash
ramsey sets up pyramid scheme john
deloney at the tip i'm i'm happy to
all day
this crap is going to get this is not
going to go well some liberal left-wing
newspapers are going to think you're
serious
because they can't do math either
oh god d you won life don't pay a bank
three or four or five percent god no and
call yourself sophisticated no don't
that's sophisticated that's just stupid
in fact call it borrow me call the
contractor in and say i have forty
thousand dollars in cash yeah and this
sixty thousand dollars is it's not an
it's
yeah real money
i got 40 grand i'm gonna hand it to you
in in cash i want this work done in my
life it's done after of course and
they're gonna line up in front of your
house yeah yeah well not these days but
yeah it's there's a lot of people that's
true
that's a labor shortage because of the
government but
anyway that it's uh d don't go into it
honey please don't go into it you have
the money you've earned it you win at
life you did a good job pay cash for
your home repairs the other interesting
thing is in addition to all of this
stuff is that when you spend the forty
thousand dollars in cash or fifty
thousand two things will occur one john
is correct you'll get better deals
uh and the reason is number two you're
more careful it is interesting to me
that when all of us when we spend 100
bills out of our checking account
we are more careful with those than we
are with borrowed money
so i had a i had a buddy uh back when i
was in college and he worked with some
home builders and he said i could always
tell the millionaires versus the middle
class people buying in this building in
this neighborhood he said it was the
millionaires who came in with the
newspaper flyer and they said uh i said
i wanted this sink because it was on
sale at this place at this time and you
all put in that sink versus the middle
class buyer that came in and said we
don't know what do you think and it was
this attention to detail and this
attention to
the dollars because it's real money
versus some big loan that's right that's
right
and folks never never do something for
the tax deduction you're trading you're
trading a dollar for a quarter where
does that come from
uh i hear that all the time comes from
the real estate business okay we used to
teach people oh it's smart to be in debt
because you get a tax deduction
i did that crap actually when i was 18
and stupid
when i got my real estate license you
need the tax deduction get a bigger loan
yeah
trade a dollar for a quarter matter of
fact trade a hundred dollars for 25 it's
even a better deal
you don't want to go pay off your home
you'll lose the tax deduction yeah one
of the things we address in fpu yes
absolutely